my name is Grace and this is Josh and we
are graduate students at the University
of Tennessee in Knoxville thank you for
coming today to listen to us talk a
little bit about using Mathematica for
higher-level thinking in calculus last
semester we were able to teach calculus
with Mathematica using a design by dr.
Brodsky at the university of tennessee
this semester we had the opportunity to
create our own version of calculus 3
with Mathematica so today I'm going to
talk a little bit about the bigger
picture in the structure that our class
fits in which is the inverted classroom
josh is then going to talk a little bit
about the goals and designing this class
and how Mathematica plays a role and
then I'll wrap up with some of our plans
for next semester so our class fits into
the big idea of an inverted classroom an
inverted classroom takes the
introduction of material and pushes it
to before class so that students are
first exposed to the material on their
own and they can develop a basic
understanding of it and then in class we
focus on working on problems either
together or individually a nice way to
think of this or visualize it is with
Bloom's taxonomy so Bloom's taxonomy
gives a nice a picture of the process of
learning for an inverted classroom
students are first kind of build that
basic foundational knowledge and a
little bit of comprehension outside of
class which is thought to be easier to
do and then in class we solidify the
comprehension and move forward to
possibly applications and analysis so we
work together in class to kind of do a
higher level learning how this works in
our world is that before class students
read notes and watch some videos to get
that knowledge base and then they do
practice problems
that basic introductory material that
allows them to build some kind of
comprehension of what's going on in
class we spend a day doing an activity
which either focuses on application or
analysis of the material so some kind of
higher-level concept and then we also
have a day dedicated to problem solving
so where students can work together or
individually and ask us questions and
see what's going on so this is the big
idea of the structure of our course that
it fits into and I'm going to turn this
off for a second so we can pass it over
to Josh and you can talk a little bit
more about how Mathematica comes into
play with this okay so now I want to
talk a little bit about our primary
goals for course design so how do we
want to design this course and what are
we trying to accomplish so we had a few
different goals in mind so are really
our first one was to make sure we had
really clear student expectations what
were we expecting of our students what
were they going to do we really wanted
to make that crystal clear from day one
and continue to our mind and throughout
the semester and our second goal is
really to make really nice manageable
notes and that's kind of vague so I want
to talk about what I mean by that okay
so so there's really two primary ideas
so one is we want these goals to these
excuse me these notes to be manageable
for our students so this means they
shouldn't be too too long or too complex
right remember this is where our
learning starts our students haven't
seen the material yet when they're
reading these notes so they need to be
very basic and easy to digest another we
wanted to make sure that it was a
complete core of material so what I mean
by this is that it it covers the basics
and doesn't branch out too much but the
notes stand alone so later sections in
the notes don't rely on extra things
we've covered earlier only the notes
themselves okay so its standalone and a
third goal which kind of goes along with
the
first and second is we really wanted
this to be easier for new instructors to
pick up the notes and to use them and to
adapt them to their own classes so they
could create their own auxiliary
materials to go with the notes third as
this is kind of the primary point of the
talk is we wanted to engage their
students and higher thinking during the
class this is just a general goal and
kind of going along with the third goal
we wanted to focus on conceptual
understanding instead of computation
we're doing multivariate calculus and as
many of you may be aware if you don't do
this there is an awful lot of
computation that you can have to wade
through in calculus 3 so how did we want
to focus on conceptual understanding
first we really wanted to steep it in a
geometric viewpoint its multivariate
calculus so there's lots and lots of
pictures we wanted to make sure students
could see these and maybe even create
their own pictures on their own so they
can have that viewpoint that everything
is geometric and we wanted to focus on
some main ideas one was linearization
limits additivity and then lastly just
coordinates and different ways of
viewing the different geometries when
you're describing shapes all right so
now I want to talk about how we're going
to accomplish these goals and what
Mathematica has to do with that so how
do we use Mathematica to accomplish all
those goals so just a little bit to say
about the notes again it's a core
material pretty much we just define what
our concepts are and we try to give an
intuitive explanation there's not a lot
of proof theorem and proof and the notes
this is because i feel that theorems are
harder for the students to understand at
this point so it's mostly intuitive
explanations of why things work the way
they do and there's lots and lots of
examples in the notes we actually want
to add even more and these are often
presented through Mathematica so that we
don't really
over much of the computation and the
background we just give them an idea of
how do you approach this problem
conceptually and this is the code that
goes through those steps and the
mathematica is in the notes they can
easily work with it on their own okay so
here's a nice little sample from the
notes so what have we got here so here's
their parameterizing ellipsoid you can
see I'm mostly doing this in tech and
explaining but then I have a nice little
quip down here where I have a bunch of
mathematica code that not only computes
the the ellipse and the tangent plane
but also gives us a nice picture so
that's something that's very common in
our notes just have pictures of all the
different things that are going on and
of course the code so that they can
produce it on their own later okay all
right so let's well let's let's do this
okay so after our students has looked at
notes they do something called pre-class
practice the idea behind this is it's
fine and good to read through notes but
you need some time as a student to work
with the ideas on your own before your
has to do something more complicated and
so this is just a little notebook file
with some introductory questions and
problems and a little bit of guidance
tells the students get started on
everything so and we we present our
commands and bold and we try to
introduce them to the mathematica
commands as we go our students have no
background in Mathematica when they
enter this class so it's really really
important for us that we guide them
step-by-step so they get used to using
the programming okay so finally this is
the in-class part after we have done
notes and practice they come to class
and they do an activity so these
activities are probably the most
elaborate part of our course design and
students show up to class in a computer
lab and they work together in small
groups usually three or four students in
a group and they do a bunch of stuff and
a notebook file so notebook file
typically has a little introduction
in and then some stuff for them to work
through and these are these are very
important these involve Mathematica
because we asked them to do a lot of
computation in just one class period and
it's not really doable without
Mathematica so here's a nice example
where we have them look at limits along
different paths and plot it and see that
it's not continuous at the origin and
then they can prove it by looking at
excuse me by looking at several paths so
you can say they get several answers
okay here's a different one where we're
looking at more of an application vector
fields we had them look at electric
fields plot some of them and we also had
them look at divergence and curl and
discovering some of how the math they've
learned relates to physics and different
applications and the last little example
this one is is probably my favorite here
this is really asking them to dig deep
and a concept that's I think is very
challenging for our students which is
the second derivative test our students
are not required to have linear algebra
before they take count three and most of
them don't know very much linear algebra
so dealing with the second derivative
test and finding I ghen values for for a
hessian matrix doesn't mean much to them
they don't know what an eigenvalue is
and so this activity we tried to let
them visualize that so they looked at
the linearization of the gradient which
uses the Hessian and they can see what
the eigenvalues means something in this
vector field might have to do with
directions of going in and out so so
being able to visualize that allows them
to understand something that normally
they don't have the tools to do just
really cool and so the last part of what
we're doing after they've done
activities and kind of built them up
made them ready we gave them work on
homework on their own and then finally
at the end of the unit they take an exam
and then all of their homework and all
of their exams is done in math
echo and they're allowed to use any
command they like and this makes
computation pretty simple because
they've got a lot of power here with
Mathematica and so to kind of make sure
that there's a check on here they're not
just coding things in that they don't
understand actually most of the grade is
from explaining their answers so they
have to explain in text in words what's
what's going on how does their solution
work and why does it work and here's a
nice little quip from an exam of a
student solution so we asked them to
find a distance between a circle and a
line and you can see they have a little
list of how they're doing it and then
why that method works you can see the
code is actually a very small part of
their answer here not too too much okay
and they have a little bottom line okay
so this is our first semester
implementing these notes in these tools
but based on mid semester feedback we
already have some changes we want to put
in place for even our next unit and next
semester I looking to the beginning of
next semester we want to create a
smoother start to the course our
students have never seen or used
Mathematica before for the most part so
throwing calculus 3 and mathematica at
them all in that first couple weeks can
be a little bit overwhelming so we want
to try to figure out how to kind of ease
them in to using Mathematica it's nice
at the beginning they can check their
work by hand because we're doing vector
calculus at the beginning so it's
something that's easy to compute and
double check yourself by hand but
eventually once we get further into the
material mathematic is going to be the
main thing if you checked yourself by
hand it would take a very very long time
so in an effort to create a smoother
start we want to add more Mathematica
based explanations to the first couple
units and also to transition the
pre-class to be more of a guided
practice so that we can introduce them
maybe more fluidly to command syntax
that kind of thing so that's something
I'm actually hoping to put into place
starting next week
to create kind of this guided practice
feel instead of a list of problems and a
to-do list also something we're looking
forward to tackling for next in part
next semester is to create some videos
to go along with our notes right now we
have all the kind of written material a
handle on that but creating videos so
that we can appeal to more varieties of
learning and kind of give them options
they didn't understand understand
something when they read it may be
watching it will help or kind of playing
around with it that way so it was that's
what we're looking forward to do next
semester and next week so thank you for
listening do you guys have any questions